[Music]
already I wanted to thank you all
for being here I believe that the
previous slide still shows
the impressive collective that we
managed to unite in barely a year we
left we were twelve or so  thirteen
today we are 40 is in fact it
is all the same the element that must be
remembered, that is to say that there is
international competition on the AI of confi
ence because globally the actor
want to integrate  AI in
complex applications in be to
be is today finally it is
still relatively little the case we
are very much on the time and can not it
can scale and we are
really on a  nec boats which means
that tomorrow we will be able to
realize value has entered into business and
make applications and therefore in this
international competition it is
impossible it is important that we look
alike because otherwise we will
not succeed  to weigh and today this
program is the most g  ros European program
on the subject and its 2 by the
contribution of everyone and therefore
also of all of you that's why we
expect a lot of things so there is
another subject I will give the floor to
julia who has me  not at heart also
it is that somewhere when we talk about
trust we will also have to normalize
standardize its important elements
because for us for you for
users because somewhere
that is what at some point makes up the
contract  collective which which allows in
advance to use products in
complete safety finally in a
deployment which is also economical and
which is viable on a large scale and and
we still had a difficulty
in involving start-up players and
large groups in the framework  of a project
that we had with the as nord on the subject
and therefore we decided to make a
partnership with with france 18 in the east
subject there which I thank warmly
and because france digital represents
q  when even the start-up ecosystem in
France is a little more globally also
that we are better I still have a
lot of partnerships with you
internationally so for us it was also
important to make you heard in
these bodies at  and therefore to rely on
an actor who could represent you
judas please thank you very much
in two words I also just wanted to
congratulate the les lauriane this evening
because I find that the partnership is in
any case the initiative of
trust and  to go there
really great in full of points but if I
had to retain only two it is already the
fact that it translates on the part of
the public authorities a really
growing confidence for the start-ups and a
confidence in their capacity to
find solutions  industrial strategic issues
and so that is still
an important point of reference and
secondly it is also an initiative that
brings together start-ups, large groups and an
academic world around common work
one and we need
more initiatives like that in france
so it's still there bravo early conditions
and for the winners
so concerning the partnership of which I
am very happy to represent france
vital today in france of the horse
it is the  largest start-
up association in europe and the partnership that we have
formed with afnor and they are going to challenge
across the lg country is a partnership
which, to sum up in two words, serves
two purposes it is a partnership which will
serve to  allow start-ups to weigh
in on the current debates around the
regulation of standardization and the
standardization of
artificial intelligence on a European and international scale
to share a common vision
with us with afnor with good for whoever
was  that
it is super important for start
ups it is super important
that the vision the values of frenc
tech start ups and french tech
mes are represented and be reflected in th
standards and  t in the
guilia regulation of tomorrow
is the only way to do it is
to contribute and it is to contribute to
shaping this standard and this regulation
so we have to we have to work on it so
this partnership will allow us to
do that and secondly  the idea is to be
able to anticipate, so anticipate the
regulations and future standards that
are being developed
today, and that means
preparing and preparing for
compliance, for example, and there you have to
put it must be done very early
we are already anticipating, for example,
additional costs for certain companies
which will be affected by the new
rules
and the objective is to prepare for
these soon
so that's it in two  words
do not hesitate so we really
want to ask you because precisely
the objective is that this partnership
gives you the floor and gives you a
voice in the bodies in brussels in
the standardization bodies in europe
and in the  world so here we will come back
to you to ask you again and
again so thank you very much and good
evening
thank you very much I thank them
just before handing over to
bertrand to make the final conclusion
because I will allow myself to pass the
floor to bertrand covered conclusions
finals finally I believe I believe that
what is important is the collective
that we manage to create and that is what
will make it possible to ensure that we weigh
both at the national European and
international levels
like 6 and the  competition is fierce there
are forces sovereignty is at stake
since you can imagine that on
its applications the stakes of all
sovereignty are enormous both
on the civilian side but also on the
defense side and and this is something fundamental for us
and so that's
why we are delighted to be able to welcome you
as part of the program and as
part of the big challenge and then here I
wish you all the best for the
s  uite
bertrand I leave you concluded
[Applause]
[Music]